[APPLAUSE]
NIKO SCHROER: Hey, everybody,
and welcome to Engagement
is the New Black.
I said, my name is Niko.
I'm a BD Manager for
Google Play based out
of Berlin, looking after
Germany, Benelux markets,
and so on.
Later during this
presentation I will
be joined by the great Markus
Falk from the cool app Lifesum
to share some first hand
experience on the topic,
as well.
So probably when
you read this title,
and even now, you're like, why
is engagement the new black?
What's up with that title?
So let me quickly give
you an introduction
to where we are coming from.
Last year, at
Playtime in London,
actually, my colleague
Matteo did a wonderful talk
on what app developers
can learn from games.
I'm pretty sure a couple of
guys were here and saw that.
Quick show of hands?
OK, that's a good 50%.
Awesome.
So that talk was
super well received
and as a follow up
to that, we actually
ran a second event which
was a workshop completely
on onboarding on
conversion, which
we ran, I think, in February
in our London office
with partners from the UK,
but also all over from Europe.
Anybody that attended this
workshop in the audience?
Cool.
So one of the main things that
was discussed in this workshop
was-- one very obvious
one, that obviously you--
all you do on this
onboarding and conversion
is in order to get lifetime
value out performing
the cost per install.
Right?
That's an obvious one.
And then when you looked
into lifetime value,
and that's one thing that really
resonated with a lot of people,
it really depends on
three things heavily.
That is retention,
engagement, and monetization.
I'm not going to go too much
into monetization because we
have a full session on that
just after this today that's
going to talk all about this.
But I really want to focus
on retention engagement
because it's such an important
driver to your business.
And the question that came out
of the crowd outlined this.
So therefore, for me, this
is really the new black.
And it's really
interesting to see
how the conversation
I've been having
over the last couple of years
in this job has shifted from,
"oh, I have many downloads,"
to "I have that many installs,"
to "oh, well really do this
to really engage your user."
So it's quite a key topic.
Before we do that,
there was one thing
that's kind of the antagonist
of retention engagement.
Can anybody guess what that is?
It's churn.
Right?
The users that are not engaged
and that are not retained
is the users that are churning.
So I very quickly want
to take a deeper look
into what churn
actually means before we
move on into the
next session, where
I want to show some ways--
easy fixes-- on how to actually
engage and retain your users
before we get Marcus on stage
and share some of their
insights they have.
So let's face it, churn really
happens to the best of us.
It doesn't really matter.
I mean, it does matter, but
even if you built the greatest
product out there,
even if you're
one of the top 10 developers
on the Play Store-- most
successful-- you
would still lose
a good portion of your users.
And I think that's natural.
It's part of any business to
customer relationship, not only
the apps world, but in
basically any business.
And there are some
common things that we see
in, actually, our
industry, why that is.
So let's face them.
Let's name them.
What are some common
reasons for churn?
And I would really appreciate
if you help me there
because there are many.
Any ideas?
Just yell them out loud.
AUDIENCE: The user didn't
understand what it does.
NIKO SCHROER: Awesome.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's boring.
NIKO SCHROER: Boring.
Another one.
So I tried to come up with
as many as I could find.
Number one, usually, is
poor technical quality.
And if you saw the lounge
presentation this morning,
it was actually mentioned that
really low ratings are often
caused by technical stability.
Number two was actually spot on.
It's insufficient
value proposition.
So the product is just not
there or it's not good enough.
The third one is, maybe
the product is good enough
but you're not making
it clear to the user.
So it's not-- they don't really
know how great your product is.
Or you're just not fresh enough.
The content is outdated.
The functionality is outdated.
You're not keeping
pace with the market.
Or it's not personalized enough.
It's too interchangeable, right?
It's great, but others do
it as well and the user,
they like to try new things.
So they go to something
else and they don't know
why they should be coming back.
And I think that's a classic.
You just overdo it
on push notifications
or general communication.
That's a classic one as well.
And many, many more that I
think cause problems and that
cause you guys headaches.
And I know this from the
various conversations
I have with my partners and we
have as a team with partners.
However, what I personally
really, really love
about this industry is that
you guys never stay with,
oh, this is the problem.
It's always about, oh,
wow, this is the problem
and it's also an opportunity.
How can we actually
use these things
and turn them around
into something better?
And what I really love
about my job at Google Play
is that I work with so many
interesting and forward
thinking partners, and that
I actually have the chance
to see all these different
tactics and fixes
and so on they use in order
to retain and engage users.
And what I want to do now is
share some of the knowledge
we have gained in that
topic back to you guys.
So here's a list of about seven
common themes that I personally
think, and I learned from
various conversations
and meetings and also
preparing this topic,
that you simply cannot ignore
if you want to retain and engage
your users.
You will see these
slides more often,
so if you don't manage
to the photo just now,
it'll come back.
One short disclaimer on this.
It's by no means
an exclusive list.
There are many, many
ways or many things
that could be added to this.
And if you really feel like
there's something missing
or we should investigate
another bullet
or even if you think something
is not right on this list,
I'm very, very much looking
forward to your feedback.
And I encourage you,
just like everybody else,
to have that conversation with
me, with anybody in the room,
and keep the conversation going.
What I'm going to
do now is, I'm going
to go through each of
them in a bit more detail.
And I would invite you
to not only listen to me,
but also to kind of actively
go through your product
and think about how you you're
dealing with different things.
And you'll probably find that,
being leading developers,
you're doing a great job
on many of them already.
But first of all, there's
always room for improvement,
no matter how good it is.
And second of all,
also keep in mind
that, maybe you are very much
aware of all these things,
but maybe within
your company that's
something you can
spread more and engage
more colleagues on this.
So first things first.
Let's talk about the importance
of having a good value
proposition.
I know.
It seems super,
super obvious and it
has been mentioned
through various talks
that I've seen today.
But it's just really,
really important
to have to have
that crystal clear.
Here are some things,
or some questions,
that I think you need to
have the right answers to.
And again, it's not
necessarily only
you having the
right answers to it,
but also make sure
these answers are
known across the various
teams and across the company.
So first of all,
what is your USP?
It could be many different
things, depending
on which vertical you're in.
If you're a publisher and you
you publish news or stories,
then the quality of
the story could be one
of your selling propositions.
If you're a fitness
app, it could
be that you motivate your users
very well to actually exercise
more, and so on.
That, I think, is the
most important bit.
But also keep in mind that
your users are usually not
one homogeneous group, but there
are different user cohorts.
So there may well
be more than one USP
that is really important
for your business.
The second one is, what does
engagement mean for you?
And as trivial as that
question sounds, really think
hardly about, what is it
that you want the user to do
that actually makes them fall
in love with your product
and come back and actually
start building this relationship
with you as a developer
or as a product offering?
And third one, it kind of goes
along with number one or two.
What are the
corresponding KPI's?
Like whenever I have
conversations with partners--
and I think that's probably
the same when you have
conversations among each other--
you compare a lot of KPI's.
But it's not necessarily
that the same KPI's
are as relevant for
everybody in the room, right?
If you're, let's say,
a document storage
app that really helps me secure
all my important documents,
then actually retaining
me over a year
and having me log in once a year
maybe a super important KPI.
While if you build a social
app, on the other hand,
you want to look into sessions
per day that it generates.
So be really aware of what
KPI's are important to you.
Number two is, again, I
think a somewhat obvious one,
but I want to give you
a certain angle to it.
It's to fully utilize the
potential of the Android
platform.
And in the talks this
morning, again, we
heard a lot from Mark and
from Ellie, and [INAUDIBLE],
and so on, how much
we are investing
in making sure that the
platform grows and gives you
more and more opportunities.
However, doing this is also
a great way, or a great tool,
for engagement and retention.
In one of many great
examples, WeVideo-- it's
actually a video editing app--
they changed their whole UX
to material design and were
able to increase user engagement
by 100% from doing that,
just because the experience
became so seamless and
understandable and great
for users.
And it goes beyond that.
Adopting stuff like Android
Auto, Android TV, or Android
Wear can also make
a huge difference
on how you engage your
users with your app.
So another question
for you guys.
Are there any golf
players in the audience?
Any golf players?
There is one.
This is-- ah, there
is another one.
I thought this is Great Britain.
It's a common sport.
Anyways, if you are into golf,
you may actually know Hole 19.
It's an app.
I think it was also featured
in the opening video today.
You saw, actually,
people playing golf,
so you might be familiar
with it from that.
It's an app that gives you
all the distances and GPS
data on golf courses.
I think to have about
40,000 golf courses
in the world mapped out.
It lets you do digital
scorecards, track your scores,
and then obviously share
them with your other golfing
buddies.
They brought their app to
Google Wear and what they saw
is a 40% increase in
monthly active users,
with Android Wear
actually bringing
some of the most engaging
[INAUDIBLE] all of them.
They actually go as far that
they tend to call themselves--
or they tend to call the
app a "wear first" app,
and it makes a lot of sense.
Think about it.
You are on the golf course.
You just hit a birdie or a
hole in one or whatever it is,
and you want to track it.
It's much more convenient
to do it on your watch
and on your wrist, than
getting out your phone
and logging into the app.
So another great way to
engage and retain your users.
Moving on to the
third fix or tactic,
and that's probably
my personal favorite,
making user onboarding great.
And it also came out
of the Q&A from Peak--
what is probably the
most important thing
for engaging users?
It's user onboarding.
It's not only my
favorite topic, I also
have my favorite analogy for it.
First time user onboarding
is like a first date.
So basically, you get
all the excitement,
you get the full,
undivided attention,
and you can ask all the
questions in the world
that you want to learn about
the preferences from the other,
from your user or
from your date.
You do all this with
only one goal in mind--
to get another date.
And then hopefully another
date, and another date,
and turn this into a
long-lasting relationship.
But with all that, we
also know-- oh, sorry.
Too fast-- that it's tricky,
because there's also so
much room for it to go wrong.
So what I want to try
to do on the next slide
is give you some very
simple guidelines
of things you should
keep in mind when
you build your onboarding.
And again, go through your
onboarding along these points,
and see if you actually meet
the full amount of points
on all of these.
So the first one is, it
should be fast and seamless.
Nothing more
annoying if it really
takes forever when
I just want to get
to the actual stuff in the app.
The second, it
should be contextual
and it should be part of
the product experience.
I think that is something that
I still see so many partners
not getting to a full capacity
or doing as good as they can.
And I'll show you an
example of what I mean.
And the third is asking
users for minimal user input
while, on the other hand,
gathering all the information
you need to actually
create great engagements.
And I think that's
the tricky bit,
because it's always a very
fine line you're walking on.
One fantastic example we see
and we have a feature before,
I think, is the
fitness app Freeletics.
So Freeletics, when
you open it up,
what I really like
about it, it really
immerses you in
the product world.
You get to this
screenshot and you
think the training
has already started,
even though you don't know
what's coming for you when
you actually train.
I just want to say that.
So they really immerse you
in their product experience
and they create it for
different user cohorts.
Basically, you get
to the second screen,
you select if you are male
or female, and depending
on that, the tonality
and the screenshots
and the onboarding
really changes.
Oh, other way around.
No, this used to be animated.
So basically, if you're
a man, after this
the imagery goes into
that tonality, as well.
Also what they have
done is, they integrated
with Google Smart Lock.
So now, when I use a new device
and I log into Freeletics,
they automatically sign me in.
So they basically remove
all the friction for me
to become a sign-in user and
get that user experience right
where it left off.
A very quick run through of
what Google Smart Lock can do.
From left to right, this is
the experience a new user has.
The new user registers.
They click to register.
They select an email address.
It could be any
address that they have
saved with Android or Chrome.
Then Smart Lock fills in
the gaps-- obviously outside
of the password.
The user gets to
choose it themselves.
They're logged in.
And then on the
last screen, they
can decide if they want to save
the passwords to Smart Lock.
And actually,
across all the apps,
we see, I think, 65% of users
actually saving their passwords
and then they're in that system.
That makes it really
easy for them.
We also have two
really cool case
studies on that, which I'm
just going to talk about.
They're not on this slide.
But [INAUDIBLE] which
is outdoor activity app,
they did an A/B test where
they tested Google Smart
Lock a sign-in versus
another sign-in,
and they had a 19% increase
in sign-up conversion
with Smart Lock.
And the second one
is Zalando, which
is the shopping
app, that see 20%
of the current sign-in events
are automatic by Smart Lock.
So if this is one
of your aims, and I
think most partners
do really push
for getting users
logged in, then this
is definitely something
to consider for you.
As I said, onboarding is not
only important-- it's not only
my favorite topic, it's
also super important.
So with all super important
things in your app,
you should test, test,
and test again, right?
And iterate and test again.
And another tool that I
want to show you for that
is Firebase Remote Config that
lets you run A/B experiments.
It lets you custom control
key values within your app,
and the change-- everything
you change basically
goes live instantly.
So if you are familiar with
the [INAUDIBLE] Firebase Suite,
that's another
handy tool to look
into to to actually optimize
the onboarding workflow.
Also any other part in
your app, quite frankly.
So quick recap before I
move into the next one.
We're at number four now.
The first one was having
a clear value proposition.
Second one, leveraging
the full Android platform.
Third one, make great
user onboarding.
And number four is
actually about successfully
releasing new feature.
And I call it the kind of
younger sister or younger
brother of user onboarding
because there are so
many similarities in
how to think about it.
First of all, you remember from
the slide on reasons to churn
is, you've got to stay fresh.
Right?
And you guys know this.
You're leading developers
in your industry.
You know there is somebody
coming for you, essentially,
and you've got to move
ahead of the curve.
You've got to come
up with new features.
If you are about
content, you constantly
need to push new
content in order
to stay relevant to users.
So that's a very general
advice on that, which I think
most of you are familiar with.
When you do introduce
new features or content,
what I think is a very
simple and systematic release
methodology to follow is
to first of all test it
with beta users-- that
was mentioned before--
to make sure that it actually
works on retention engagement
metrics.
Secondly, again, ensure
technical stability.
Thirdly, really show
users what's new,
and that's actually what
the screenshot here is for.
Imagine you had never
seen this product
and you were introduced to
this and you could actually
navigate from here if
you're driving your car.
There are some very easy
ways, with material design,
to make this visually very
simple and light weight,
but yet very clear to users when
they onboard to a new feature.
And then, as a fourth
point, obviously analyze
the performance.
Again, we have a
couple of tools that
are super useful for that
For point number one and two,
beta groups and
prelaunch reports,
both were featured in
large this morning.
I'm not going to go
into them, I just
want to give it a big
fat plus one or plus
two, depending on how
you want to see it.
On prelaunch reports,
actually keep in mind
that you need to opt in.
So it's not going to
happen automatically.
So you need to go
in the console,
opt in for it to be activated,
and then every single thing you
upload to alpha/beta
actually runs these checks.
And then use cohort analysis
in Firebase Analytics
or in Google Analytics to
really check the performance
of new features.
It's one thing that
you built something
new and fancy and
cool, but you really
want to make sure
that you actually
optimize against that goal
for retention or engagement
that you have.
And as always, numbers are
best way to make a decision.
Another point you may recall
from the list we showed
of reasons why users churn is
that your app-- or an app--
may be too interchangeable with
what t competitor is offering.
One really cool
way to counter this
is to personalizing
the experience,
so to make the
user feel at home.
I think there are two
main way of doing this.
Number one is
where you basically
give the user all
kinds of manual ways
to design the experience.
You may like let them toggle
stuff in the home screen,
switch stuff on and off, and
so on, and I think all of that
is great.
Just what I think happens
quite a lot, or what we hear
happens quite a lot, that
really remains something
that mostly power
users do, and it's
really hard to get average
or the broad range of users
actually to do that.
So another way to do this is by
actually doing personalization,
by using business intelligence
to individualize the product
experience.
And I will show you
what that means.
A great example for this
that was shared with me,
actually, was from hotels.com.
They basically
anticipate user-- or they
use user behavior to
anticipate users' needs,
and provide the
relevant experience
in the right moments.
So what does that mean?
They try to map
various scenarios
for users coming into the app.
One is onboarding.
When it's about
onboarding, they try
to make it as convenient
as possible for the user
to actually go to sign-in.
When a user actually
comes back to the app--
so it's a returning user
that has searched before--
and they may show them something
that's relevant to their search
or where they were left off.
And then another scenario could
be that somebody has actually
booked a hotel with
hotels.com, and on the day
of check-in or
check-out, they will
provide relevant
information, maybe
around where people
travel, or stuff around
the hotel and information.
So they have different
scenarios where the user really
feels like this
is a personalized
experience to them.
How they do that
is, first of all,
by being aware of all of that
and actually catering for it,
but also by creating a
flexible content structure
that actually allows them to
move around content and modules
to react to this broad
range of scenarios.
And then the third one, is that
they actually exhaustively map
the context, instead of content
or action the user was left in.
So that when you leave
and you come back,
you really feel like you're
continuing where you left off.
So I think that's
a great example
of using data and a
sophisticated technical
approach to actually
provide personal user
experience for a broad range.
Some of you may probably think
now, oh, you said easy fixes.
This seems very complex.
Yes.
This is probably one of
the things that are not
that straightforward and easy
to set up, but once you have it,
it's actually a very neat way
to do that personalization.
So I think it's really worth
the effort of looking into that.
The second last I want
to talk about is having
a great communication
strategy and it
ties very much into the
personalization bit.
So push notifications is
what I'm going to focus on,
and they have become somewhat
the standard on the platform
as an engagement tool,
and rightfully so.
They work great if you
do a great job on them.
However, there's
also a fine line
between using them to drive
engagement, on the one hand,
or to actually make users churn
because you're overdoing it
or they're not relevant
or whatever it may be.
So again, some very
simple rules in order
to make the strategy successful.
First, the push notification
needs to be relevant.
So the context, the
language, the tonality
needs to be relevant
to the user.
And be creative, be
true to your brand.
Be creative.
Speak to the customer
in a unique way.
I think that's something that
I still see a lot of partners
not fully optimizing.
Second, it needs
to be actionable.
Is it an FYI?
Is it actually a call to action?
Do you want me to do something?
If so, then make sure
that is deeplinked
and that when I
actually click through,
I get to whatever
you talked about.
Because if that's not happened,
then the user experience
is really burned, and
you're like, OK, where am I?
Why am I here?
And you're probably not
going to do it again
or you're less likely to push
on opening the app again.
Then third one is-- I want to
talk about timeliness first.
Timeliness, the right
message at the right time.
Again, it seems
very obvious, but I
think the London Olympics--
oh, not the London, sorry.
The Rio Olympics were a
great example of that.
A lot of the stuff happened
overnight for users in EMEA.
So the question becomes, is
it that Usain Bolt won the 100
meters?
Or somebody broke
a world record?
Is that really more
relevant at 3:00
AM in the morning
on a Tuesday night?
Or should you be waiting
to push that message
at 7:00 AM in the morning when
you know your users get up
and actually check their news?
So there are things
to keep in mind
and not only go, oh, this is a
great thing, I'll just push it
out, because it may lose
its effect on users.
And then the fourth
point is personalization.
You should segment users,
you should have your cohorts,
and then also proactively
let users opt out of stuff
and opt into other stuff.
Especially the opt out part
seems counter-intuitive,
but let me give you one
great example where-- which
you see on the left, actually.
This is a screenshot
of Aftenposten.
It's one of the biggest
newspapers in the Nordics.
And they basically--
a while ago, they
redid their whole onboarding,
and as part of that,
a new notification
management screen and they
saw some fantastic results.
So basically, now
when you onboard,
users get to select to-- I
think this is pre-selected
and then they get to opt
out, but they're proactively
asked to do so.
So what they saw
is, first of all,
that I think over 50%
of the users actually
keep two of the three.
So they take one off consciously
but they take the other ones
because they think
they're relevant.
And then, overall, they saw
a decrease of uninstalls
by, I think, 9% over
60 days, which I think
is a strong argument
for the point I tried
to make earlier where too many
push notifications, or not
having a strategy, can be
really be something that leads
to churn, while it should be
really something that helps you
engage and retain users.
And then also, another
interesting side effect,
is that they really
learned about their users
and the preferences
of those users.
And to my surprise,
apparently there
were less users
interested in sports
than in the other topics.
For me, usually, that's
exactly the other way around.
Again, just to
highlight one tool
that you can use
for that very well,
is Firebase Cloud Messaging.
It lets you target individual
devices, cohorts, and so on.
Super reliable and
it's cross-platform.
It doesn't only
work for Android,
so you can use it across
the platforms-- [INAUDIBLE]
and iOS, as well.
Last but not least,
rewarding use engagement.
Let's talk a bit about that.
I think, very generally, this
should be something everybody
should be thinking about from
the perspective of making
it really desirable for
your users to become
an engaged user with you.
And when they are
engaged user, really
reward them and show
you that you value that.
Obviously it's a
topic, and this is
something I realized more than
ever when I started researching
it for this talk,
that you can go
really deep in when it comes to
gamification and the mechanics
around it and so on, right?
And there are many
great strategies,
and probably with a
lot of the gaming guys
here, they could go on
about this for length
and without any end.
However, it can already start
with very simple rewards
mechanism.
It's a broad range.
It's a large spectrum
of stuff you can do.
And what works for your app
really depends on your app,
on your industry, what
business model you have,
a free [INAUDIBLE], and so on.
However, if you're not
doing anything at all,
and I think you
should, then you can
start with keeping
it very simple,
thinking of something that adds
value to your users, and makes
sense and fits with
your overlap ecosystem.
So a couple of good examples
are inviting power users
to early access to test
beta features and so on.
Give them a special
preview, right?
It's a very simple one, but you
wouldn't believe how many users
really love that.
And I do it for a
lot of the products
that I love, too, where I
proactively tell the developer,
please include me
in product testing
just because I love
the product so much.
The second one are badges.
How do I know that?
Because you guys all love it.
Whenever it's about a badge on
Google Play, people go crazy.
Top Developer Badge,
Editor's Choice, and so on.
And usually the ones that
go most crazy are the devs.
Maybe sometimes
the business people
we talk to, they're
like what's the impact?
What's that?
And they talk about
all these numbers,
and then we talk about that.
But then, when they get it,
they tell me, oh, my Android
developers freaked out.
We're like best of that,
we're part of here.
So really giving
these simple badges.
Usually it doesn't
cost you anything,
it just needs--
you need to come up
with a structure
on how to do it,
and you can really show
users how valued they are.
And then you can do
stuff like offering app
exclusive discounts.
Generally, the more
you can endeavor
individualize that, the better.
But again, starting off
with a very broad range
and basically just
showing users that you
value that they are
there and go from there,
is a really good start.
The bottom line
is, these engaged
users are your best customer
and they should be valued.
Because who does not
like to be valued?
So here are the seven
fixes again in an overview.
I think you had enough
from me for now.
This was quite a lot
of input, I think.
So it's time for some
first-hand experience,
and I would like to welcome
Markus Falk from Lifesum
up on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
MARKUS FALK: you, Niko.
So now I feel very gamified
around the badges things.
Cool.
So I guess a lot of
you probably think
that I'm here to present
the secrets around the Holy
Grail of retention.
If I happen to do
something like that,
please feel free to share
that with me because that
would be some fantastic
knowledge to have.
But as Niko said, I'm Markus.
I'm from Lifesum and I think
that retention and engagement
is probably the most interesting
topic because it's basically
tells you how good
is your product.
I mean, if your users are coming
back, it's a good product.
So that's the one metric that
should be above everyone else,
I think.
So we're just going to give you
a bit of an insight around how
we think around retention
at Lifesum and engagement.
So starting off
with a little bit
about us, but also what
retention engagement
means to health in specific.
Then a little bit of what we
track and why we track it.
And then I have two
examples, one where we tested
and failed miserably and
the other one where we
tested and actually succeeded.
It's nice that you can
set off this agenda,
because it looks like it's
a 50/50 split there, which
might not always be the case.
And then I'm rounding
up with a few takeaways.
So start with a bit about us.
I think there are a few
things within health
that needs to be fixed.
So today, health care is
actually a lot about sick care.
You wait until you get sick
and then you get treated.
But instead, it
should be that you
do a lot of stuff
with your lifestyle
before you actually get sick.
I mean, the way you eat, how you
train, exercise, how you sleep,
stress levels, et cetera,
will affect your life.
So that's basically
what we are here for.
We are here to sort
of help you with that
But then when we talk about
engagement and retention
I think it's kind
of interesting when
it comes to health
because no one has really
sold it in a good way.
And I don't think that's
all about just health apps.
I think it's for the
health sector, in general.
Let's take gyms for example.
I think in the US
you have about 70%
of people that own a
gym subscription isn't
going to the gym.
And you have-- when it comes
to medication or medical
and pharma-- about 50% of
people who are on medication
isn't taking them properly.
So the challenge
is, how do you get
people to think it's
interesting and fun to take
care of themselves?
Which is hard.
But of course, within
this sort of industry,
you can be either good or
you can be bad at this.
And I think that Lifesum
is-- we're not the worst.
We're definitely not
the best, either.
But for us, it's definitely--
the number one company
goal is to work on retention.
It's the stuff that we
talk about every day.
It's definitely the key for us.
So we haven't figured it
out, but we are trying
to do a lot of stuff around it.
So a little bit about what
we track and why we track it.
So we have a few
standard metrics
that we follow on a daily basis.
So we look at seven
day retention.
We look at week five retention.
And we look at
week 53 retentions.
Of course we do deep dives,
et cetera, within those,
but these are the ones
that are standard.
So what we noticed was that when
the users come into the Lifesum
app a lot of them
has actually decided
that they want to change
something with their lines.
They want to become healthier.
So they're super engaged
in that very first moment
when they come into the app.
But then what we've seen is
that they rapidly drop off
during the first seven days.
So for us, the number
one metric to follow
has been the 7-day metric.
But then, most
recently, we've started
to think a little bit
different around retention.
That you shouldn't really treat
it the same way for all users
because it's kind of
different depending
on what you want to achieve.
So we looked at
the data and we see
that we have basically four
different types of users--
the monster, the focused, the
dieter, and the long term.
I named them.
So let's say the
dieter for example.
In the US, the average American
goes on a diet about four times
a year, which is quite a lot.
It's crazy, I know.
And that diet will last from
anywhere between a few days
to a few weeks.
So for us, then, it's important.
So instead of trying to force
the dieters behavior to become
the monster, which is tracking
every day for several months,
we should just recognize,
OK, this person is on a diet.
We need to make the
app as good as possible
for them to come back
for the next diet.
So that sort of
thinking, like OK,
if we can put these people
in different buckets,
we should treat
them differently.
So two examples.
Let's start with a sad one.
So we had this knowledge
about that users are very
motivated in their first visit.
So we thought that
if we can get them
to invest a lot of time and
energy in the app at first,
they will be coming back.
So we basically created
this massive health test
of 41 questions.
We brought in consultants,
nutritionists, et cetera.
We built it into
the onboarding flow.
We put it on the profile page.
We prompted it several times.
It was a massive project.
It took us months to develop.
And then when we release it, of
course, we were super excited.
This is going to have a massive
impact on seven-day retention.
And now everyone's just waiting
for the data and when it came,
it was the sound of
no hands clapping.
Nothing happened.
So of course, it
was a big failure.
But then of course, with
failures, you usually
get some stuff out of it.
For us it was, I
think, first we managed
to confirm that we have the
high initial motivation.
So out of the people starting
the test, we had about 90%
completing all 41 questions.
So within a few weeks, we had a
million of these test results,
and that data is
kind of valuable.
I mean, first of all,
this info you can see, OK,
how many percent is a
vegetarian in London compared
to Stockholm, for example.
But also referring to the
buckets that I talked about,
we can actually profile
users now based on this data.
So it's something that
we're not doing yet
the way we should be
doing it, but it's
a really interesting source.
But of course, from a retention
perspective, it wasn't good.
And I think what we learned from
that is also what the guys have
been talking about before.
You need to find
ways of testing stuff
before you put a lot
of effort into it.
So we often did stuff
that was working out.
So going back a few
months, we didn't really
have any sort of social
interaction in the app.
And I think the reason for
that was that we didn't really
know what people wanted to
share, because when it comes
to your personal health,
especially around weight loss,
it's not that you want to
like-- you don't want to share
everything on Facebook.
Let's put it that way.
So what we did here
is that we created
this very small, intimate
social feature, very simple,
and we ran a test in Sweden.
So it's basically that you
could invite up to five friends
to become your sort of team.
And within that team you could
basically push each other
and motivate each other, but
you could also remind people
if they were dropping off.
So when we got that out, we
saw that people on social
actually had a 2x increase
in seven-day retention, which
was, of course, fantastic.
But if you think about it, it's
like if you have five people,
and three of them drop off,
and they have two more that
can keep reminding
them, that's always
going to be better than if
you have like five silos where
no one can talk.
So from that perspective,
it was really good.
What we had some issues with
there was the adoption rate.
We didn't really got that
many users to be on social.
So we popped a survey
for them who declined
and the reason
was still privacy.
I don't want to share my data.
So this is still a big challenge
for us to try to figure out,
but also massive potential.
So yeah, wrapping
up a little bit.
I mean, looking at your
own users' retention
is interesting.
So not just treating
retention the same way
across different apps or
even across your own users
or try to find what
are your patterns.
For us, it might be very
high initial motivation
or that we have a lot
of dieters in the app,
but it might be
different for you.
And then social is key.
If you can get your own users
to help you with retention,
it's always going to be good,
referring to the health test
that we did.
And I think that
everyone is saying this
but it needs to be said
over and over again,
is that you need to find
easy, quick ways of testing
your ideas before
you spend hundreds
and thousands on building them.
Cool.
So yeah, back to Niko to
sort of wrap it up a bit.
[APPLAUSE]
NIKO SCHROER: Thank you, Markus.
Yeah, so it's great to see
that a lot of the points
resonated with you, at least.
That's a start.
So very quickly-- I know
you guys are waiting
for another coffee break.
That's what I think is
happening after this.
Before we do that, I want to go
back on the one summary slide.
This is actually Dr. E. E
is obviously for engagement.
And this is his checklist that
he uses to go through his apps.
So I encourage you
to take this list.
Take a screenshot or actually
take it later from YouTube,
and take it home with you.
Go through it with
your teams and see
what are things you are doing.
What other things
you are doing good?
What are the things
you are doing great?
And wherever you are
not great, really
think about how you
can actually get there.
So we hope this was
useful for you guys.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]